Narrator:
TONIGHT, SPECIAL GUEST SHARK
BILLIONAIRE CREATOR
OF THE GoPro CAMERA NICK WOODMAN
JOINS THE TANK.
FINALLY!
IN THE TANK,
ENTREPRENEURS SEEK AN INVESTMENT
TO START, GROW,
OR SAVE THEIR BUSINESS.
AMERICA'S FIGHTING A BATTLE
WE MUST WIN!
THIS DUDE'S PASSIONATE,
AND I DIG IT.
IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GREAT IDEA...
THAT'S PRETTY COOL.
...THEY'LL INVEST
THEIR OWN MONEY...
I LOVE YOUR PRODUCT.
GIVE ME A HUG.
THIS IS OUT OF
THE GoPro PLAYBOOK --
[ SNORES ]
...AND FIGHT EACH OTHER
FOR A DEAL.
YOU KNOW WHAT? JUST STOP.
JUST STOP TALKING.
AND SO, I --
JUST LET ME FINISH.
YOU KNOW WHY
HE NEEDS TO STOP TALKING?
YOU DEFINITELY DO NOT WANT
THIS GUY AS AN INVESTOR.
LET ME FINISH.
SILENCE! PLEASE.
Narrator:
BUT THE ENTREPRENEURS MUST GET
THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR,
OR THEY'LL WALK AWAY
WITH NOTHING.
YOU MAY THINK
IT'S A PIECE OF CRAP...
I DO.
BUT I DON'T CARE.
THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT MATTERS TO ME PERSONALLY.
GET OVER IT.
DON'T START CRYING. BE A MAN!
Narrator:
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE
BUSINESS EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS
A SHREWD VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE
SELLING A CHILDREN'S
EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
DAYMOND JOHN DOMINATED
THE FASHION WORLD WITH FUBU.
NOW HE'S THE BRANDING EXPERT
BEHIND MULTIPLE GLOBAL BRANDS
GENERATING BILLIONS IN SALES.
LORI GREINER, THE QUEEN OF QVC,
HOLDS OVER 100 PATENTS
AND HAS LAUNCHED
OVER 400 PRODUCTS,
GROSSING OVER A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES.
MARK CUBAN,
RENOWNED BILLIONAIRE TECH MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
AND NICK WOODMAN,
CREATOR OF THE GoPro CAMERA,
TURNED HIS PRODUCT
INTO A CONSUMER AND MEDIA EMPIRE
WORTH MORE THAN $8 BILLION.
BAM!
GOOD LUCK, ROOK.
GOOD LUCK, NICK.
THANK YOU.
ONE MORE.
THERE'S ONLY ONE RULE
IN "SHARK TANK" --
DON'T SCREW IT UP.
[ LAUGHS ]
Narrator:
FIRST INTO THE TANK
IS AN INNOVATIVE WAY
TO CONTROL BAD HABITS.
Man: HERE WE GO.
FIVE, FOUR...
HERE WE GO.
Man #2:
FOUR, THREE --
Man:
FOUR, THREE, TWO --
[ EXHALES SHARPLY ]
HELLO, SHARKS.
I'M RYAN TSENG.
AND I'M DAVID KRIPPENDORF!
YES, YOU ARE.
WE ARE THE CREATORS
OF THE KITCHEN SAFE
BASED IN SAN FRANCISCO,
CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE SEEKING $100,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR A 5%
EQUITY STAKE IN OUR COMPANY!
SHARKS, AMERICA'S FIGHTING
A BATTLE WE MUST WIN!
THE ENEMY IS
JUNK-FOOD TEMPTATION,
AND IT IS EVERYWHERE!
[ CHUCKLES ]
AT WORK --
BOWLS OF CANDY.
AT HOME --
CHIPS, CHOCOLATE, CAKE,
AND DON'T EVEN GET ME STARTED
ON GIRL SCOUT COOKIES!
[ LAUGHS ]
IT'S NO WONDER
THAT 2/3 OF US ARE OVERWEIGHT!
THERE HAS TO BE
A BETTER WAY!
INTRODUCING
THE KITCHEN SAFE.
THE KITCHEN SAFE
IS A REVOLUTIONARY
NEW TIME-LOCKING CONTAINER
THAT HELPS YOU FIGHT TEMPTATION.
IT'S FUN, EFFECTIVE,
AND EASY TO USE.
PICTURE THIS,
SHARKS --
LET'S SAY THAT DAVID IS
A SERIAL MIDNIGHT MUNCHER,
BUT BEFORE
THOSE CRAVINGS SET IN,
ALL DAVID HAS TO DO
IS PLACE THOSE TEMPTATIONS
IN THE KITCHEN SAFE.
NEXT, HE ROTATES THE DIAL
TO SET THE TIMER.
AND FINALLY, HE PRESSES THE DIAL
TO ACTIVATE THE LOCK.
ONCE THE KITCHEN SAFE
IS LOCKED,
IT CANNOT BE OPENED
UNTIL THE TIMER REACHES ZERO.
THE KITCHEN SAFE IS GREAT
FOR SO MANY THINGS --
TV REMOTES, VIDEO GAMES,
CREDIT CARDS, AND CELLPHONES --
YOU NAME IT.
CAN'T STOP SNACKING
BEFORE DINNER?
KITCHEN SAFE!
ARE YOUR KIDS
PLAYING VIDEO GAMES
INSTEAD OF DOING
THEIR HOMEWORK?
KITCHEN SAFE!
THIS GUY'S FANTASTIC.
LOOKING TO BREAK
A BAD HABIT?
KITCHEN SAFE!!
[ LAUGHTER ]
THE KITCHEN SAFE
IS GREAT
FOR JUST ABOUT
ANY UNWANTED TEMPTATION.
IT'S WHAT PSYCHOLOGISTS CALL
A COMMITMENT DEVICE,
AND IT IS SCIENTIFICALLY PROVEN
TO FIGHT TEMPTATION.
AND BASED
ON OUR CUSTOMER FEEDBACK,
WE KNOW IT WORKS.
ONLY ONE QUESTION
REMAINS --
WHICH OF YOU SHARKS
WILL LOCK UP A DEAL WITH...
KITCHEN SAFE!
[ LAUGHS ] YAY.
ARE YOU LIKE THIS
AT HOME?
John: ALL RIGHT.
WOW.
NOT REALLY.
NOT USUALLY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
SO,
DO WE GET TO SEE ONE?
ABSOLUTELY.
YES. DAVE WILL HAND OUT
SOME SAMPLES.
LORI.
Greiner:
AH, THANK YOU.
KEVIN, YOU SHOULDN'T BE
SURPRISED, BUT GREEN.
YES.
I LIKE THAT A LOT.
DAYMOND.
THANK YOU.
OUR WHITE COLOR,
WHICH IS ACTUALLY
OUR TOP SELLER.
AND, MARK --
NO SURPRISE.
THANK YOU, SIR.
APPRECIATE IT.
Greiner: SO, YOU TURN IT TO
WHATEVER TIME YOU WANT IT TO BE.
YES.
[ WHIRRING ]
OH, THERE IT WENT.
MINE'S LOCKED.
[ CHUCKLES ]
[ LAUGHS ] OKAY.
AND THE ONLY WAY TO UNLOCK IT
IS FOR THE TIMER TO GO DOWN?
THAT'S RIGHT.
THERE ARE NO OVERRIDES.
NO OVERRIDES?
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?!
YEAH.
DO YOU GUYS HAVE KIDS?
I DO.
I HAVE A 3-YEAR-OLD.
OKAY,
SO YOUR 3-YEAR-OLD --
YOU PUT IN
HIS FAVORITE CANDY,
AND YOU SET THIS
TO THREE HOURS.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA HEAR
FOR THREE HOURS
FROM THAT 3-YEAR-OLD?
ONE OF THE BENEFITS OF THIS IS,
WHEN I WAS A KID,
MY PARENTS USED TO CALL
AND SAY "TIME OUT.
WE'RE GONNA TAKE AWAY YOUR TOY
FOR THE REST OF THE DAY."
AND WHAT HAPPENS IS
YOU NAG THEM, YOU NAG,
AND EVENTUALLY,
THEY WOULD GIVE IN.
BUT WITH THIS,
THEY PUT IT IN THERE,
AND YOU LOCK IT,
YOU SET IT FOR SIX HOURS,
AND YOU SAY,
"YOU KNOW WHAT?
"SORRY. I CAN'T
GET INTO IT, EITHER."
Woodman: YEAH.
"YOU SHOULD HAVE LEARNED.
THAT'S IT."
EXACTLY -- YOU'RE OFF THE HOOK
AS A DAD,
'CAUSE YOU'RE JUST SAYING,
"LOOK, I CAN'T OPEN IT."
BUT WHO CARES
WHAT THE SHARKS THINK?
WHAT DOES THE MARKET SAY?
HAVE YOU SOLD ANY OF THESE?
WE'VE SOLD $300,000
SINCE WE'VE LAUNCHED.
WE'VE ONLY BEEN SHIPPING
FOR 11 MONTHS.
ONLINE OR IN RETAIL?
ABOUT 90% OF OUR SALES
ARE ONLINE
THROUGH
OUR DIRECT CHANNEL.
HAVE YOU EVER TALKED TO
A RETAILER ABOUT STOCKING THIS?
WE JUST STARTED
APPROACHING RETAILERS.
AND WHAT DID THEY SAY?
Greiner: WHO?
UH, WE HAVE A P.O.
WITH HSN.
I'M TALKING
ABOUT SHELF SPACE.
WE HAVE NOT STARTED
REACHING OUT TO RETAILERS
WITH A LOT OF SHELF SPACE
AT THIS TIME.
WHAT DOES IT COST YOU TO MAKE,
AND WHAT DO YOU SELL IT FOR?
CURRENTLY,
IT COSTS US $14.50 TO MAKE.
HMM.
WE SELL FOR $49 RETAIL.
OH!
REALLY?
$49?!
$49?! HOLY CRAP.
$49 IS A GOOD INVESTMENT
FOR A PRODUCT
THAT HELPS YOU LIVE
A BETTER, HEALTHIER LIFE.
BUT WHEN THIS FINALLY
OPENS UP,
DO YOU JUST EAT EVERYTHING,
LIKE A JUNKYARD DOG?
LIKE I WOULD? YEAH.
[ LAUGHS ]
Krippendorf:
I MEAN -- LET ME FINISH.
FINALLY!
YOU KNOW, MY GOAL IS NOT TO
BECOME AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,
BUT WHAT I DO THINK I CAN DO
IS I CAN HAVE THAT MODERATION.
I CAN SET IT
FOR, LIKE, 7:00 P.M.,
AND THEN I WON'T HAVE
ANY COOKIES UNTIL THEN.
AND, YES,
YOU CAN BREAK IT,
BUT IT'S A VERY EXPENSIVE THING
TO BREAK TO HAVE A COOKIE.
BUT HOW DO YOU DEAL WITH
THE SKEPTICISM I HAVE
THAT THIS PRODUCT
IS REALLY JUST A TCHOTCHKE?
THERE'S NO REAL MERIT.
THEY IGNORE YOU.
THAT'S HOW THEY DEAL WITH IT.
NO, IT DOES SOMETHING.
IT ACTUALLY IS ADDRESSING
A CONSUMER PROBLEM.
YOU KNOW, I DON'T THINK
AMERICA'S GONNA SPEND $49 --
NO,
IT'S TOO EXPENSIVE.
THE COST OF MAKING THIS
IS WAY TOO HIGH.
Greiner: IF YOU CAN
BREAK IT DOWN FROM $14.50,
HOW MUCH LOWER DO YOU THINK
THAT YOU CAN GET?
WE THINK WE CAN GET IT DOWN
TO $10, $12, OR EVEN LOWER.
DO YOU HAVE
ANY TYPE OF I.P. --
PATENTS --
THAT PROTECT THIS CONCEPT?
YEAH, WE HAVE, UH,
FOUR PATENTS PENDING.
ONE OF THEM IS
A DESIGN PATENT.
YOU KNOW, WE DO BELIEVE
THIS WILL END UP IN RETAIL.
WE HAVE TALKED
TO MANUFACTURERS' REPS
WHO HAVE BEEN VERY EXCITED
ABOUT THE PRODUCT,
AND THEY ARE STARTING
TO TALK TO, YOU KNOW,
RETAILERS OUT THERE --
THE BIG BOXES.
BUT THAT'S PART OF WHAT WE'D
LIKE YOUR HELP WITH, AS WELL.
THIS SEEMS LIKE,
AT A $29.99 PRICE, YOU'D HAVE --
John: THE LOWEST
THEY CAN GET THIS, THOUGH,
IT LOOKS LIKE, IS $10,
WHICH MEANS, AT RETAIL,
IT WOULD BE APPROXIMATELY $40.
Woodman:
YEAH, EXACTLY.
YOU'D HAVE TO MORTGAGE
YOUR HOUSE TO HIDE YOUR COOKIES.
KITCHEN SAFE IS MAYBE
A LITTLE BIT LIMITED
AS A COMPANY NAME,
BECAUSE YOU'RE GONNA WANT
TO GROW INTO NEW PRODUCTS
AND PERHAPS NEW VERTICALS
WHERE THIS IS NOT EVEN
IN THE KITCHEN.
I MEAN,
I WAS REALLY LUCKY.
ORIGINALLY,
I JUST MEANT FOR GoPro
TO BE
A SURF-CAMERA COMPANY,
AND THANKFULLY, I DIDN'T
NAME THE COMPANY "SURF CAMERA."
SO I DON'T THINK THAT PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO NATURALLY THINK
TO PUT ANYTHING
OTHER THAN FOOD IN THIS.
Greiner:
HE'S EXACTLY RIGHT...
MM-HMM.
BUT THE BEAUTY OF IT IS
THAT YOU COULD TAKE --
AND JUST WITH PACKAGING
DO DIFFERENT PACKAGING
FOR DIFFERENT THINGS.
YEAH.
I REALLY WANT TO GET
TO THE VALUATION NOW.
PLEASE DON'T GO THERE.
NO. IT'S NOT WORTH $2 MILLION,
YOU DON'T THINK?
THE MARKET VALUE
FOR OUR COMPANY
IS HIGHER THAN WE'RE OFFERING
THE SHARKS.
ALL RIGHT, WE DON'T CARE
ABOUT MARKET VALUE HERE.
THAT'S WHY YOU'RE HERE,
RIGHT?
WELL, I DO.
John: YOU DO?
[ LAUGHS ]
YOU GOT TO LEAVE, THEN,
'CAUSE YOU COULD GET THE MONEY.
WELL, WE DON'T
JUST WANT THE MONEY.
WE WANT THE EXPERTISE.
LET ME HELP
CLEAR THE AIR HERE, OKAY?
THIS PRODUCT ISN'T
GOING TO ACTUALLY WORK
UNLESS
IT'S VERY INEXPENSIVE.
Woodman: YES.
TO ME, SOME ELEMENT OF IT
IS TCHOTCHKE.
WHY DO YOU KEEP
SAYING THAT?
TCHOTCHKE IS JUST STUFF
THAT SITS THERE.
LET ME FINISH, ALL RIGHT?
THIS DOES SOMETHING.
LET ME FINISH.
RIGHT.
PEOPLE USE IT.
IT WORKS.
IT IS WHAT IT IS.
I'M LISTENING, AND IT SAYS,
"I'M A PIECE OF CRAP."
THERE ARE PEOPLE OUT THERE
WHO E-MAIL US EVERY DAY
AND CALL US AND TELL US
HOW IT'S MADE
A HUGE IMPACT IN THEIR LIFE.
THIS DUDE'S PASSIONATE.
YOU'RE STRIKING A NERVE.
AND SO MAYBE TO YOU,
IT'S A $15 PIECE OF CRAP...
HE'S PASSIONATE,
AND I DIG IT.
YOU GOT EMOTIONAL.
THAT'S A GOOD SIGN.
O'Leary:
LET ME FINISH, OKAY?
SO, WHEN I LOOK AT IT AND SAY,
"HOW DO I MAKE MONEY?" --
WHICH IS
ALL I CARE ABOUT --
I'LL SELL A PIECE OF CRAP
IF I CAN PROFIT FROM IT.
I HAVE NO PROBLEM AT ALL
DOING THAT.
I DO.
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT CAPITALISM
IS, ALL RIGHT?
THAT'S NOT
WHAT THIS IS ABOUT FOR ME.
YOU MAY FALL INTO
THE "PIECE OF CRAP" CATEGORY.
KEVIN! IF YOU SAY
"PIECE OF CRAP" ONE MORE TIME --
YOU DEFINITELY DO NOT WANT
THIS GUY AS AN INVESTOR.
LET ME FINISH!
SILENCE! PLEASE!
LET ME FINISH.
WE'RE NOT INTERESTED IN MAKING
A PIECE OF CRAP, KEVIN.
NO, LOOK, I SAID,
"CAN I MAKE MONEY?"
YOU KNOW WHAT? JUST STOP.
JUST STOP TALKING.
AND SO, I --
JUST LET ME FINISH.
YOU KNOW WHY HE NEEDS
TO STOP TALKING?
LET ME FINISH!
NO. I'M NOT EVEN GONNA
LET HIM FINISH.
YOU DO NOT WANT HIM
AS AN INVESTOR.
LORI, I BEG YOU.
I'M NOT EVEN GONNA
LET HIM FINISH,
ARE YOU GONNA
ASK HIM AGAIN
BECAUSE I'M SICK OF HEARING HIM
SAY IT'S A PIECE OF CRAP.
HOW YOU CAN LOWER
THE COST OF THE GOODS?
AND I'M GONNA MAKE YOU
AN OFFER.
OH! EXCELLENT.
THANK YOU, KEVIN.
LET ME HELP.
I'M OUT.
THANK GOD.
[ CHUCKLES ]
Krippendorf: I WANT SOMEONE
WHO BELIEVES IN THIS
AND THE FACT
THAT THIS HELPS PEOPLE OUT.
I MEAN,
IT'S GREAT TO MAKE MONEY,
BUT THIS MATTERS TO ME
A LOT.
I DON'T NEED THIS MONEY.
I CAN SURVIVE.
I CAN PAY MY BILLS WITHOUT THIS.
THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT MATTERS TO ME PERSONALLY.
AND SO YOU MAY THINK
IT'S A PIECE OF CRAP...
I DO.
BUT I DON'T CARE.
I UNDERSTAND.
SO DON'T GO BUY IT
AND DON'T --
DON'T OFFER US MONEY.
WELCOME TO THE REAL WORLD,
MY FRIEND,
'CAUSE SOME PERCENTAGE
OF THE PEOPLE OUT THERE,
INCLUDING INVESTORS,
THINK IT'S A PIECE OF CRAP.
THAT'S FINE.
I'M ONE OF THEM, OKAY?
I'M INTERESTED
IN THE PEOPLE THAT --
DEAL WITH IT.
GET OVER IT.
DON'T START CRYING. BE A MAN!
Narrator: KEVIN IS OUT,
AND HE'S CONFRONTED
DAVID AND RYAN
ON THE MERITS
OF THEIR LOCKABLE CONTAINER,
KITCHEN SAFE.
THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT MATTERS TO ME PERSONALLY.
AND SO YOU MAY THINK
IT'S A PIECE OF CRAP,
BUT I DON'T CARE.
I'M INTERESTED IN THE PEOPLE
THAT CARE ABOUT OTHER PEOPLE,
HELPING PEOPLE OUT,
TO MAKE MONEY AT THE SAME TIME,
AND THAT'S GREAT.
I HOPE THAT HAPPENS.
AND THAT'S
WHAT I'M LOOKING FOR.
SO, YOU KNOW WHAT? I KNOW
THERE'S A MARKET OUT THERE.
I KNOW
IT'S A GREAT PRODUCT.
WE'RE GONNA GET THE PRICE DOWN
TO WHAT WE NEED TO DO,
BUT FRANKLY,
EVEN AT A $49 PRICE,
IT WORKS,
AND THAT MAKES ME HAPPY.
WELL SAID.
Greiner:
AND TELL -- TELL ME --
John: I LIKE YOUR PASSION,
SO HERE'S MY OFFER --
$100,000 FOR 20%.
AND I'D LIKE TO HEAR
WHY IT MEANS SO MUCH TO YOU.
I'VE SEEN A LOT OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE OVERWEIGHT,
AND...IT'S HARD.
IT'S HARD TO HAVE
THAT TEMPTATION
AROUND YOUR HOUSE
EVERY DAY.
WE USED TO BUY
A THING OF ICE CREAM,
AND WE'D EAT HALF OF IT,
AND THEN I'D THROW IT AWAY
BECAUSE IF IT WAS THERE,
I WOULD EAT IT.
I'M THE SAME WAY.
AND SO, YOU KNOW, FOR ME,
THAT'S WHAT IT STARTED WITH,
AND WHEN I --
YOU KNOW,
WE DEAL WITH THE CUSTOMER
E-MAILS ALL THE TIME,
AND WHEN SOMEONE'S LIKE,
"THANK YOU.
"I'VE BEEN LOOKING FOR THIS
FOR 10 YEARS.
I FINALLY FOUND SOMETHING
THAT MAKES A DIFFERENCE,"
THAT KEEPS ME GOING.
WHAT I REALLY AM TOUCHED BY,
I HAVE TO SAY, SITTING HERE,
IS YOUR EMOTION
TO HIM GETTING UPSET.
I MEAN, IT SHOWS
YOU REALLY LOVE THE GUY.
STRONG TEAM.
AND I'M GOING TO GIVE YOU
AN OFFER.
I'LL GIVE YOU $100,000
AT A 20% EQUITY STAKE MYSELF.
I HAVE ONE CONTINGENCY.
YOU GUYS ARE
ABOUT TO GO ON HSN.
I WOULD LIKE YOU
TO BE ON QVC INSTEAD.
I MEAN,
I KNOW WHAT I CAN DO ON QVC,
AND I CAN MOVE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
BUT I -- BUT I ALREADY HAVE
A DEAL WITH HSN,
SO WE CAN KEEP THAT RELATIONSHIP
AND MAKE IT EVEN STRONGER.
OKAY.
SO, I'LL -- I'LL COME IN
WITH ANOTHER 100K
IF SHE'LL PARTNER
WITH ME...
YOU WANT TO JOIN ME?
...BECAUSE
I LOVE THE POTENTIAL.
I THINK YOU NEED
SOME MARKETING HELP.
SO, ARE YOU ASKING
FOR 40% TOTAL?
DO YOU WANT TO DO IT,
INSTEAD, AT 30%?
50% AND 50%?
200K, 30%.
AND CONTINGENCY --
YOU CANNOT DO HSN.
AND THEN, MY --
BUT YOU CAN DO QVC.
YEAH, AND THEN,
MY DEAL IS...
LIGHTS, CAMERAS,
CUSTOMERS.
...$100,000, 20%,
AND I'M ALREADY WITH HSN,
SO I WOULD WORK WITH YOU THERE.
BUT I ALSO HAVE
DIRECT CONNECTION
AND MY OWN SECTION NOW
AT BED BATH & BEYOND LAUNCHING.
I'M GLAD I INTRODUCED YOU
TO THEM, YES...
THIS IS A PERFECT
BED BATH & BEYOND --
'CAUSE THAT WAS MY DEAL.
HE DID NOT.
ANYWAY, SO --
WE -- WE MADE AN AGREEMENT
TO DO HSN.
YOU KNOW,
I THINK THAT --
WHICH IS FINE,
AND YOU CAN DO IT --
IT'S OUR OBLIGATION
TO DO THAT
BECAUSE WE SAID
WE WERE GONNA DO THAT.
THAT'S IMPORTANT TO ME.
YES, AND I UNDERSTAND THAT.
YOU COULD GO ON
AND FULFILL THAT PURCHASE ORDER.
Cuban: AND IF THEY
ASK YOU BACK AGAIN --
IF IT'S SUCCESSFUL
AND THEY ASK YOU BACK AGAIN?
IF WE'RE WORKING WITH LORI,
THEN I-I --
THEY WOULD UNDERSTAND
WHY YOU LEFT.
THEY WOULD UNDERSTAND?
YES, THEY DO.
SO YOU THINK
A COMPETITOR WOULD SAY,
"OH, PLEASE,
GO TO MY COMPETITOR...
NO. YOU KNOW WHAT?
...BECAUSE I UNDERSTAND."
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND WHEN YOU HAVE
A FINANCIAL PARTNER...
YEAH.
...THAT IS
SOMEWHERE ELSE
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO GO
TO THAT OTHER PLACE.
OKAY.
SO, YOU HAVE TWO OFFERS.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
UNLESS MARK'S DECIDING
TO DO SOMETHING WHICH
WE HAVEN'T HEARD.
Krippendorf:
I MEAN, I PERSONALLY THINK,
YOU KNOW, THAT THE COMPANY'S
WORTH MORE THAN THAT --
A LOT MORE THAN THAT.
APPARENTLY NOT.
YOU'VE GOT TWO OFFERS.
WE HAVE A BETTER OFFER
FOR YOU.
LORI AND I
HAVE REVISED OUR OFFER.
WE'RE NOW OFFERING YOU
$100,000 FOR 20%,
MATCHING DAYMOND'S OFFER.
'CAUSE WE'RE PASSIONATE
ABOUT THIS.
IT REMINDS ME
OF WHEN I STARTED GoPro.
YOU'RE NOT JUST SELLING CRAP,
LIKE O'LEARY THINKS YOU ARE.
THERE'S PURPOSE
TO WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
BOTH OF US
BELIEVE IN YOU,
AND WE BELIEVE IN WHAT WE CAN
ALL DO TOGETHER AS A TEAM.
AND THEY OBVIOUSLY
DON'T LISTEN VERY WELL,
'CAUSE YOU'VE SAID
MULTIPLE TIMES
THAT YOU BELIEVE
THE VALUATION IS FAR HIGHER --
MARK, YOU GONNA MAKE AN OFFER
OR GIVE THEM A LECTURE?
I'M JUST LISTEN--
I'M JUST WAITING,
LETTING THESE GUYS TALK
'CAUSE THEY LIKE
TO HEAR THEMSELVES TALK.
GUYS, I SAID EXACTLY
WHAT THEY SAID 20 MINUTES AGO,
WHEN NOBODY ELSE WAS
ON THE TABLE.
WILL YOU DO 20%
FOR $200,000?
Greiner: NO.
NO.
AH, REALITY.
Woodman: AND HERE'S
THE REASON WHY.
IT'S BECAUSE
WE'RE ACTUALLY GOING TO
BECOME INVESTED PERSONALLY
IN YOUR BUSINESS
AND HELP YOU GUYS SUCCEED.
MARK, ARE YOU OUT?
NO.
OH, MY GOD.
[ LAUGHS ]
I NEVER SAID I WAS OUT.
John: GUYS, YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'M NOTICING
YOU COUNTERED OVER THERE,
AND THEN
YOU'RE TALKING TO MARK.
YOU ALREADY KNEW
WHERE KEVIN WAS HEADING.
YOU'RE NOT EVEN
ADDRESSING ME,
SO MAYBE I'M NOT
THE RIGHT PERSON...
[ LAUGHS ]
THAT YOU WANT
TO DO THE DEAL WITH.
I DON'T WANT
TO BLUR YOUR VISION.
WE'RE ABSOLUTELY INTERESTED
IN WORKING --
OKAY, I THINK YOU SHOULD BE
TALKING TO ME AND THEM.
WELL, I THINK WE'RE INTERESTED
IN HEARING EVERYONE'S OPINION,
AND --
YES, BUT YOU KNOW WHAT?
WE LIKE DECISIVE PARTNERS.
YOU HAVE TO
MAKE A DECISION.
Let's just take it.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
WE REALLY WANTED TO WORK
WITH LORI AND NICK,
AND ALSO DAYMOND,
WHEN WE CAME IN,
BUT WE GET
TWO OF YOU GUYS.
YEAH.
WE WOULD BE THRILLED
TO TAKE YOUR OFFER.
WHOO-HOO!
YAY.
Tseng: THANK YOU SO MUCH,
DAYMOND.
Woodman:
HEY, NICE WORK.
[ GREINER LAUGHS ]
DO YOU MIND
IF I DOCUMENT THIS MOMENT?
OH, GoPro.
[ CAMERA BEEPS ]
GROUP HUG!
[ GRUNTS ]
NOW YOU GUYS HAVE
A GREAT OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE'RE GONNA
GET THAT PRICE DOWN.
SWEET!
CONGRATS, ROOK.
GOOD JOB.
THANK YOU.
John:
I LOVE YOUR PASSION.
YOUR DECISION-MAKING SUCKS.
Krippendorf: I'M REALLY EXCITED
THAT WE HAVE NICK AND LORI.
OUR GOAL WAS NOT JUST
TO BUILD A SMALL COMPANY.
WE WANT TO BUILD THIS INTO
A $100-MILLION-A-YEAR COMPANY,
AND I BELIEVE THAT THIS IS GONNA
BE A HUGE STEP FOR US.
MY NAME IS CAMERON SHELDRAKE.
I'M FROM ITHACA, NEW YORK.
AND I'M THE FOUNDER
OF OFF THE COB.
MY FAMILY FARM HAS BEEN
OPERATING HERE SINCE THE '60s,
SO, NATURALLY, FARMING IS
A HUGE PART OF MY LIFE.
ONE OF THE CROPS WE GROW
A TON OF IS FRESH SWEET CORN.
EVERYONE IN MY FAMILY LOVES IT,
INCLUDING MY DOG.
Sheldrake:
OH, IS THAT GOOD, BARRY?
UNFORTUNATELY,
OUR SUPPLY OF FRESH SWEET CORN
OFTEN OUTWEIGHS THE DEMAND,
SO WE END UP
THROWING AWAY A LOT.
I HAD TO FIND SOMETHING
TO DO WITH THIS CORN,
SO I MADE A PLAN TO CHANGE IT
FROM WASTEFUL TO TASTEFUL.
THERE'S A NEED FOR MY PRODUCT
BECAUSE PEOPLE DON'T KNOW WHAT
THEY'VE BEEN MISSING OUT ON.
IT WAS
REALLY GOOD PICKING.
MY BUSINESS IS
REALLY IMPORTANT TO ME
BECAUSE WE'RE HELPING
TO SUSTAIN MY FAMILY FARM,
AND SO IF I DON'T GET A DEAL
FROM THE SHARKS,
I DON'T KNOW WHAT I'LL DO.
HI. I'M CAMERON SHELDRAKE,
AND MY COMPANY IS OFF THE COB.
I'M SEEKING $100,000 IN EXCHANGE
FOR 10-- OR 15%...
[ LAUGHS ]
...OF MY COMPANY.
IT ALREADY WENT UP?
WHICH WOULD YOU RATHER EAT --
SWEET CORN OR GRAIN CORN?
DID YOU KNOW
THAT MOST TORTILLA CHIPS
ARE MADE WITH GRAIN CORN?
GRAIN CORN HAS HARD, DRY KERNELS
AND A STARCHY FLAVOR.
IT'S MACHINE-HARVESTED
IN THE FALL,
ONCE THE PLANT HAS DIED
AND THE KERNELS HAVE HARDENED
ON THE COB.
GRAIN CORN IS USED
MOSTLY TO FEED TO ANIMALS
AND TO MAKE ETHANOL.
I PREFER FRESH SWEET CORN,
LIKE YOU'D BOIL OR GRILL
AND EAT RIGHT OFF THE COB,
AND THAT'S WHY I STARTED
OFF THE COB
SWEET CORN TORTILLA CHIPS.
WE MAKE THE FIRST
AND ONLY TORTILLA CHIPS
WITH FRESH-PICKED SWEET CORN.
SWEET CORN GIVES OUR CHIPS
A SAVORY, SWEET,
REAL CORN-ON-THE-COB FLAVOR,
NOT THAT BLAND, STARCHY FLAVOR
GRAIN CORN GIVES MOST CHIPS.
NOT ONLY DO OFF THE COB
SWEET CORN TORTILLA CHIPS
TASTE BETTER,
BUT THEY'RE BETTER FOR YOU.
THEY'RE MADE WITH ORGANIC,
NON-GENETICALLY MODIFIED CORN.
THEY'RE GLUTEN-FREE,
NO CHOLESTEROL, NO TRANS FAT,
AND VERY LOW SODIUM.
SO, SHARKS, WHO WANTS TO HELP ME
CHANGE THE CHIP IN YOUR DIP?
ARE YOU GONNA
LET US TRY SOME?
OF COURSE.
GREAT.
GREAT NAME, BY THE WAY.
THANK YOU.
Woodman: IT SAYS IT ALL
IN THE NAME, AND IT'S FUN.
THANK YOU.
SOME SALSA.
Woodman:
GREAT PACKAGING, TOO.
Sheldrake: YEAH, WE JUST
LAUNCHED THIS NEW PACKAGING
ABOUT TWO MONTHS AGO.
THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE IT.
HOW LONG AGO
DID YOU LAUNCH THIS?
THIS IS VERY GOOD.
WE'VE ONLY BEEN SELLING CHIPS
FOR 13 MONTHS.
WHERE IS IT SOLD?
IT'S SOLD
IN NATURAL GROCERY STORES,
SUCH AS WHOLE FOODS AND WEGMANS
IN THE NORTHEAST.
IT'S HARD
TO GET INTO WEGMANS.
HOW MANY STORES?
WE'RE IN 45 STORES
RIGHT NOW.
I HAVE A QUESTION.
I NEVER REALIZED
THAT THE TORTILLA CHIPS
OR CORN CHIPS THAT WE EAT
ARE FROM GRAIN CORN.
IT'S VERY EXPENSIVE TO PUT
THE SWEET CORN IN THE CHIP.
IT'S ACTUALLY
20 TIMES MORE EXPENSIVE
THAN CONVENTIONAL CORN.
MM.
WE'RE PAYING $5.50 A POUND
FOR DRIED SWEET CORN.
MOST GRAIN-CORN FLOUR COSTS
ABOUT 30 CENTS A POUND.
Greiner: SO, WHAT IS
A BAG OF THESE...
WOW.
WHOA.
REALLY?
...COMPARED
TO A BAG OF CHIPS
THAT IS GRAIN CORN
THE SAME SIZE?
MOST CONVENTIONAL TORTILLA CHIPS
ARE, LIKE, 99 CENTS.
WE'RE A LITTLE BIT
MORE EXPENSIVE.
WE'RE AT $3.49
AT WHOLE FOODS.
WE WERE ACTUALLY
IN 20 WHOLE FOODS AT ONE POINT,
BUT WE WERE OUT OF STOCK
FOR SO LONG, WE LOST OUR SPACE,
SO RIGHT NOW, I'M BATTLING
TO GET BACK THAT SPACE.
THEY TASTE GREAT,
BUT THE DELTA IN PRICE
BETWEEN THE 30 CENTS
I CAN BUY GRAIN CORN FOR
AND THE $5
I HAVE TO PAY FOR THIS,
IT'S NOT REFLECTED, IN MY VIEW,
IN THE TASTE DIFFERENCE.
WELL, I THINK THERE'S
A GROWING AMOUNT OF PEOPLE
THAT ARE LOOKING FOR SOMETHING
THAT'S HEALTHIER.
NO, I GET --
THAT'S ON-TREND,
BUT THEN
YOU RUN INTO THE PROBLEM
WE'VE SEEN MANY TIMES
ON "SHARK TANK"
WHEN PEOPLE COME IN
WITH HEALTHIER OPTIONS
AND THEN RUN INTO
THAT GRAVITY OF DISTRIBUTION --
THE CHALLENGING
OF CONVINCING LARGE --
THERE'S WHOLE FOODS
EVERYWHERE.
WHAT HAVE YOU SOLD, TOTAL,
IN THE LIFETIME?
ABOUT 45,000 SO FAR.
THAT'S YOUR SALES?
DOLLARS?
YEAH.
YOU'RE NOT
MAKING ANY MONEY YET.
NO.
OKAY.
IF ANOTHER YEAR GOES BY
AND YOU HAVEN'T MADE ANY MONEY,
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
WELL, THAT'S NOT GONNA HAPPEN,
BECAUSE IN JANUARY,
WE'RE STARTING WITH THE LARGEST
DISTRIBUTOR OF NATURAL FOODS
IN THE UNITED STATES
AND GOING OUT TO 100 STORES.
WHAT ARE YOU MAKING IT FOR
RIGHT NOW?
RIGHT NOW,
IT'S ABOUT 85 CENTS.
OH!
Greiner: PER BAG?
YEAH.
WHAT DO YOU SELL IT
TO THE DISTRIBUTORS FOR?
FOR $1.60 TO $1.70
PER BAG.
YOU KNOW,
I HAVE A VERY SIMPLE MODEL.
IF THE BUSINESS,
AFTER THREE YEARS,
ISN'T MAKING MONEY,
I CALL IT A HOBBY.
AND IF IT'S NOT
A HOBBY OF YOURS,
YOU SHOULD TAKE IT
BEHIND THE BARN AND SHOOT IT.
SO YOU HAVE
ANOTHER 12 MONTHS
TO PROVE
THAT THIS THING CAN MAKE MONEY.
I FIND YOUR COST INSANE.
LOOK, THERE'S NOTHING WRONG
WITH THE PRODUCT. I LIKE IT.
BUT YOU HAVE TO SIT AROUND
AND EXPLAIN TO EVERYBODY
THAT IT'S DIFFERENT,
AND THAT'S PART
OF YOUR MARKETING CHALLENGE.
I DON'T WANT
TO TAKE THE RIDE WITH YOU,
'CAUSE I DON'T THINK THE OUTCOME
IS GONNA BE A GOOD ONE.
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
CAMERON,
I THINK THESE ARE GREAT.
UM...THE CHALLENGE IS, THOUGH,
AS AN INVESTOR,
I HAVE TO BE ABLE
TO SEE MY WAY TO A RETURN --
2X, 5X, 7X, 10X --
WHATEVER IT MAY BE.
LET ME TELL YOU
ABOUT MY PLAN FOR GROWTH.
TELL ME
ABOUT YOUR PLAN FOR GROWTH.
OKAY, SO, 2014,
WE'RE GONNA BE IN 400 STORES.
AND HOW MUCH REVENUE
WILL THAT CREATE?
THAT'LL CREATE $1.1 MILLION
IN REVENUE.
AFTER ALL THE COSTS,
IT'S ABOUT A 15% NET PROFIT.
SO THAT'S $165,000
IN NET PROFIT, HOPEFULLY, RIGHT?
AND THEN WE HAVE TO
REINVEST THAT INTO THE BUSINESS
AND WE HAVE TO
KEEP ON GROWING IT.
IT'S GONNA BE A GRIND,
RIGHT?
GOING INTO
THE ORGANIC-SNACK-FOOD MARKET --
IT'S VERY, VERY COMPETITIVE,
IT'S NOT EASY.
BUT YOU HAVE A UNIQUE PRODUCT,
BUT I JUST DON'T --
I JUST DON'T THINK
I CAN GET A RETURN QUICK ENOUGH,
AND SO, FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
OKAY, MARK.
YEAH, CAMERON,
SOME CLOSE PEOPLE IN MY LIFE
HAD TO BECOME GLUTEN-FREE
RECENTLY,
SO I'VE BEEN TASTING
A LOT OF GLUTEN-FREE PRODUCTS.
OKAY.
IT'S REALLY GOOD.
AND I REALIZED
HOW CHALLENGING IT IS
FOR SHELF SPACE,
LIKE O'LEARY ALWAYS SAYS.
I JUST THINK
THAT IT'S AN UPHILL BATTLE
THAT I-I CAN'T TAKE
WITH YOU.
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
BUT GOOD LUCK.
THANK YOU.
Greiner:
I THINK THEY'RE WONDERFUL.
I DON'T REALLY BUY
TORTILLA CHIPS THAT MUCH,
AND I WOULD BUY THESE.
I LOVE THAT YOU'RE DOING
SOMETHING DIFFERENT
WITH SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN
THE SAME FOR SO MANY YEARS.
BUT I DO THINK IT WILL BE
VERY, VERY DIFFICULT
FOR US TO SCALE AND FOR ME
TO GET BACK MY MONEY ON THIS.
AND FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
IF I BOUGHT ONE OF THESE
AND ATE IT,
I WOULD BUY IT AGAIN
AND EAT IT AGAIN.
AT $3?
YEAH.
I WOULD NOT BE
THAT PRICE-SENSITIVE TO THIS.
I THINK THAT THE PACKAGING
IS FABULOUS.
IT'S FUN. IT MAKES YOU HAPPY
WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT.
I THINK "OFF THE COB" --
PEOPLE GET IT RIGHT AWAY.
IT SOUNDS FRESH.
THE MARKETER IN ME
WANTS TO INVEST IN THIS,
BUT THE BUSINESSMAN IN ME
DOESN'T KNOW HOW TO SCALE
A BUSINESS LIKE THIS.
MM-HMM.
I WANT YOU
TO STICK WITH THIS,
'CAUSE YOU ARE
GOING TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
[ SNORES ]
YOU'RE GONNA GRIND,
LIKE MARK SAID...
O'Leary: UGH.
...BUT I'M OUT.
THESE ARE FABULOUS.
THANK YOU, SHARKS.
John: ALL RIGHT, MAN.
GOOD LUCK.
John: GOOD LUCK.
Greiner: GOOD LUCK.
O'Leary:
GOOD LUCK, CAMERON.
YOU WILL SUCCEED.
Sheldrake:
I'M A LITTLE DISAPPOINTED
THAT NONE OF THE SHARKS
MADE AN OFFER.
I'VE WORKED REALLY HARD
FOR THIS,
AND WE'RE GONNA KEEP DOING
WHAT WE'RE DOING
AND KEEP SELLING CHIPS.
Narrator: NEXT UP IS
A UNIQUE WAY TO COOK ON THE GO.
HI, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS SHARON YU.
TODAY, I'M SEEKING $100,000
FOR 20% OF EQUITY IN MY COMPANY,
MAGIC COOK, THE FIRST
OUTDOOR, ON-THE-GO COOKER
FOR ANYONE, ANYWHERE, ANYTIME.
NOW, WITH THIS LITTLE CONTAINER,
I'M ABOUT TO SHOW YOU
HOW TO COOK
A HOT, DELICIOUS SALMON MEAL
WITH NO POWERS, NO BATTERY,
NO GAS, AND NO FIRE.
FIRST, ADD FRESH SALMON
AND SOME VEGGIE.
NOW ADD OUR MAGIC HEAT PACKS
INTO BOTTOM
OF THIS PLASTIC CONTAINER.
ADD WATER.
NOW TRANSFER
THE STAINLESS-STEEL CONTAINER
INTO PLASTIC CONTAINERS.
NOW LOCK THE LID ON TIGHT.
IN ABOUT 30 SECONDS, THE WATER
WILL START TO RAPIDLY BOIL.
WOW.
WHAT?!
AFTER 24 MINUTES LATER,
IT'LL BE ALL DONE.
I HAVE A MEAL HERE
THAT I PREVIOUSLY STARTED
JUST LIKE
THOSE FANCY COOKING SHOWS HERE.
[ CHUCKLES ]
A PERFECTLY COOKED
SALMON STEAMED MEAL.
IT'S JUST THAT SIMPLE.
WANT A HOT DRINK OR SOUP
WITH YOUR MEAL?
NO PROBLEM.
OUR MAGIC COOK BOTTLE
CAN DO THE SAME MAGIC FOR YOU.
YOU CAN HEAT UP ANY SOUPS
OR ANY BEVERAGES.
NOW, SHARKS,
WE JUST LAUNCHED.
I NEED YOUR HELP TO MAKE
MAGIC COOK A HOT COMMODITY.
THANK YOU.
THAT'S
REALLY INTERESTING.
[ LAUGHS ]
I'D LIKE TO -- YES?
SHARON,
WHO NEEDS THIS?
I NEED IT.
YOU NEED IT.
WHY DO I NEED IT?
YOU EAT LUNCH.
WHY DON'T I JUST GO GET
A HOT MEAL AT A RESTAURANT?
CAMPING, RIGHT?
FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE,
THEY PREPARE FOR OUTDOORS.
SO, THIS IS FOR THE OUTDOORSMAN
THAT HAS NO OTHER OPTION?
IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE.
Cuban: NO, I COULD SEE YOU
TAKING IT TO THE OFFICE.
SOME PEOPLE WORK AND WORK HARD,
AND SO WE EAT AT OUR DESKS,
AND WE PREFER TO EAT
SOMETHING THAT WE LIKE.
BUT THERE'S NO MICROWAVE
IN YOUR OFFICE.
YOU CAN'T AFFORD THAT,
RIGHT?
[ CHUCKLES ]
WELL, I CAN SEE THIS
WORKING REALLY WELL AT MY DESK.
REALLY?
THIS IS OUR LUNCH BOXES.
AND --
THANK YOU.
YOU CAN TAKE ONE.
MR. WONDERFUL.
THANK YOU.
I'LL TAKE THIS ONE.
Greiner: WHAT IS INSIDE OF IT
THAT'S MAKING THAT BOIL?
UM, THE HEAT PACK
CONSISTS OF QUICKLIME,
SO IT HAS CALCIUM, SODIUM.
WE HAVE A TEST REPORT
TO SUPPORT THAT IT'S NONTOXIC.
IT'S SAFE TO USE.
SO, I CAN SEE IT AS SORT OF
PART OF AN EMERGENCY KIT,
BUT IF I EVER FOUND MYSELF
IN A PLACE
WHERE I HAD TO USE THIS
TO EAT DINNER,
I KNOW I'VE TAKEN
A WRONG TURN SOMEWHERE.
[ CUBAN LAUGHS ]
[ LAUGHS ]
EXPLAIN THE ECONOMICS.
WHAT DOES IT COST YOU
TO MAKE EACH ONE?
WHERE ARE YOU SELLING THEM NOW?
HOW MUCH HAVE YOU SOLD?
SURE. THE LUNCH BOXES
ARE $6.50 TO MAKE.
AND WE HAVE ONE PACKS --
INCLUDING ONE HEAT PACK --
AND WE SELL IT FOR $29.99.
FOR THE CUPS,
IT'S $4.75 TO MAKE
AND ALSO
WITH ONE LITTLE HEAT POUCH,
AND WE SELL IT FOR $19.99.
AND WHERE ARE YOU
SELLING THEM NOW?
DICK'S SPORTING GOODS,
SPORTS CHALET, UM, CABELA'S.
SO TOWARDS
THE OUTDOORSMEN MARKET
IS WHERE
YOU'RE SELLING THEM NOW.
OUTDOOR MARKETS, YES.
HOW MUCH ARE THE PACKS?
FOR THIS FIVE PACKS,
THE COST TO MAKE IS $2.
AND WHAT
DO YOU SELL IT FOR?
AND WE SELL IT FOR $9.99.
AND WHERE
ARE YOU MAKING THIS?
CHINA.
HOW HAS YOUR EXPERIENCE BEEN
MAKING IN CHINA?
WELL, MY BACKGROUND
IS PROMOTIONAL PRODUCT INDUSTRY,
SO I'VE BEEN
IN THE MANUFACTURING BUSINESS
FOR THE LAST 15 YEARS,
SO TO DEAL WITH CHINESE PEOPLE,
IT'S A PIECE OF CAKE FOR ME.
WHAT HAVE YOUR SALES BEEN
TO DATE?
WE JUST LAUNCHED IT
FOR ABOUT A YEAR.
LAST YEAR, WE HAVE
ABOUT $150,000 IN REVENUE.
OOH.
SO, HOW MANY HEAT PACKS
ARE YOU SELLING?
'CAUSE THAT'LL KIND OF
GIVE US AN IDEA
OF HOW MUCH PEOPLE ARE ACTUALLY
USING IT AND REUSING IT.
YES, THE HEAT PACKS --
WE SOLD 35,000.
WOW!
YEAH,
FOR THE LARGE ONES --
SO ONCE YOU BUY IT, YOU HAVE TO
KEEP BUYING THE REFILLS.
THAT'S CORRECT.
O'Leary: I MEAN,
IT'S A NICHE PRODUCT.
9 OUT OF 10 PEOPLE
DON'T NEED THIS.
WELL, DO YOU EAT LUNCH?
YEAH, BUT I DON'T NEED THIS
FOR LUNCH.
[ LAUGHS ]
YOU KNOW, WHEN
A NATURAL DISASTER STRIKES,
IF YOU HAVE A WATER BOTTLE,
WHAT CAN YOU DO WITH IT?
YOU CAN JUST DRINK, RIGHT?
THAT'S IT.
CAN YOU COOK WITH IT?
NO.
THIS IS JUST AN OPTION.
YOU CAN GO OUT THERE AND FISH,
GET A FRESH FISH,
AND COOK IT, RIGHT?
[ GROANS ]
SO, IT'S THE SAME PRICE --
$19.99.
THAT'S TOUGH.
YOU KNOW WHAT? LOOK...
NO, IT'S HARD
WITH THAT ONE.
...IS THERE A UTILITY
FOR THIS? YES.
YES.
PERSONALLY, I THINK GOING FOR
THE CAMPING MARKET IS ALL RIGHT.
THIS IS NOT
AN INTUITIVE PRODUCT
TO BUY WITHOUT SEEING
THE DEMONSTRATION, RIGHT?
YEAH.
MM-HMM.
THAT'S WHAT MAKES THIS
A TOUGH DEAL.
SOMEBODY HAS TO DO A LOT OF WORK
TO...PREPARE FOR THIS.
THE HAVE TO PLAN AHEAD.
PEOPLE AREN'T GONNA TAKE --
IT SEEMS LIKE A SURVIVAL,
SORT OF DISASTER --
THIS IS NOT GONNA BE
AN IMPULSE BUY.
"OH, YEAH. WAIT --
OH, GEEZ.
I CAN COOK MY OWN SALMON
AT WORK," RIGHT?
IT'S GOT TO BE SOMETHING
THAT TRIGGERS THAT, RIGHT?
WELL --
I JUST DON'T SEE IT,
AND FOR THOSE REASONS, I'M OUT.
SORRY TO HEAR THAT.
SO -- SO,
A REALLY IMPORTANT THING
WHEN YOU COME UP
WITH A CONCEPT
IS THAT YOU SOLVE
A PERVASIVE PROBLEM FOR PEOPLE
AND YOU DON'T TRY TO CREATE
A NEW WAY TO DO SOMETHING
THAT ISN'T NECESSARILY
BROKEN.
AND SO, FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
OH.
I'M SORRY TO HEAR THAT.
O'Leary: LOOK, I UNDERSTAND
THE MARKET FOR THIS.
THERE'S ALWAYS SOMEBODY
WHO THINKS THE WORLD
IS GONNA END TOMORROW.
YES. YES.
AND THEY SHOULD HAVE THIS.
FINDING THAT PERSON IS
THE BIG CHALLENGE.
I'M NOT EVER GONNA BE
THAT PERSON HANGING OFF A ROCK,
UNLESS SOMEBODY
CARRIES ME UP THERE.
WELL --
I DON'T DO CAMPING.
CAMPING SUCKS.
I'M OUT.
FOR ME,
MY SHARKONOMICS 101 --
IS IT SOMETHING
PEOPLE NEED AND WANT?
IS IT GONNA FILL
A BROAD AUDIENCE?
IS IT SOMETHING THAT CAN BE MADE
AT AN AFFORDABLE PRICE?
I'M SORRY.
CAN I ASK YOU THIS --
CAN YOU JUST USE THIS
AS A REGULAR WATER BOTTLE?
I FEEL THERE'S TONS
OF COMPETITION
OUT THERE FOR THIS --
TONS.
MM-HMM.
AND I THINK
IT NEVER MAKES SENSE
TO GO OUT
AGAINST SOMETHING
WHERE THAT SOLUTION'S
ALREADY BEEN MADE
BY A MILLION DIFFERENT
MANUFACTURERS SUCCESSFULLY.
I DON'T THINK IT'S THE RIGHT
INVESTMENT FOR ME,
SO I'M OUT.
SORRY TO HEAR THAT.
THANK YOU.
THAT LEAVES ONE SHARK --
DAYMOND.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO,
DAYMOND?
Yu: DAYMOND?
Narrator:
FOUR SHARKS ARE OUT.
DAYMOND IS SHARON'S LAST CHANCE
AT MAKING A DEAL
FOR HER SELF-HEATING
FOOD CONTAINER, MAGIC COOK.
DAYMOND?
WHY DO YOU FEEL
YOU NEED A PARTNER?
I'VE BEEN IN THIS INDUSTRY
FOR ABOUT 15 YEARS,
AND I HAVE NO PARTNERS.
I NEED SOMEBODY
TO CHALLENGE ME,
AND I THINK
YOU CAN DO THAT.
YOU CREATE
A BEAUTIFUL PRODUCT.
YOU KNOW THIS.
YOU KNOW SOURCING.
YOU KNOW EVERYTHING ELSE
LIKE THAT,
SO I'M GONNA TAKE A FLIER
WITH YOU,
BECAUSE I THINK THAT,
IF THIS WORKS OR DOESN'T,
THERE'S STUFF
FOR US TO DO TOGETHER.
YOU ASKED
FOR $100,000 FOR 20%.
20%. YES.
$100,000 FOR 33%,
WE HAVE A DEAL.
$100,000 FOR 33%.
ARE YOU GONNA
THINK ABOUT THAT?
COULD I MAKE A PHONE CALL
TO MY LAWYER?
NO.
YOU CANNOT MAKE A PHONE CALL
TO YOUR LAWYER.
[ LAUGHS ]
YOUR HUSBAND, YOUR SPOUSE,
YOUR MOM, YOUR DAD,
BUT NOT
A BLOODSUCKING LAWYER.
I WANT TO DEAL
WITH THE DECISION-MAKER...
OKAY.
...BECAUSE WE WILL HAVE TO
MAKE DECISIONS TOGETHER,
AND I DON'T NEED
A LAWYER AROUND,
BECAUSE THEN I HAVE 19 LAWYERS
THAT YOU COULD TALK TO.
IT'S A BIG DECISION.
LET ME THINK FOR A MINUTE,
BECAUSE IT TOOK ME A YEAR
TO GET HERE.
IT TOOK ME 45 YEARS
TO GET HERE, SO...
$100,000 --
GIVE ME A HUG.
[ LAUGHTER ]
WHAT DID YOU SAY?
SHE DID IT.
OH! SORRY!
GIVE ME A HUG.
YOU DID IT.
[ LAUGHS ]
THAT'S LESS THAN A MINUTE.
I LIKE THAT.
YES.
ALL RIGHT.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
[ LAUGHS ]
John: ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
Cuban: GOOD JOB, D.J.
CONGRATS.
Yu: DAYMOND WAS
THE SHARK I WANTED,
BECAUSE WE HAVE
SO MUCH IN COMMON --
SAME BACKGROUND.
HE HAS KNOWLEDGE
FOR MANUFACTURING,
SO WE HAVE THE SAME LANGUAGE.
SO I'M SO THRILLED
TO WORK WITH HIM.
Narrator: LAST SEASON,
EVAN MENDOLSON AND NICK MORTON
MADE A DEAL WITH ROBERT HERJAVEC
FOR THEIR
UGLY-CHRISTMAS-SWEATER COMPANY
TIPSY ELVES.
ROBERT,
WE ACCEPT YOUR OFFER.
EXCELLENT, GUYS.
O'Leary: OH!
Narrator: LET'S SEE
WHAT THEY'RE UP TO NOW.
Morton:
BEFORE BEING ON "SHARK TANK,"
WE HAD $800,000 IN SALES.
AFTER "SHARK TANK,"
WE HAD $3 MILLION IN SALES.
Mendelson:
AND THIS YEAR, WE'RE PROJECTING
$8 MILLION IN SALES.
TWO, THREE...
TODAY, WE'RE HAVING
A MASSIVE PHOTO SHOOT
FOR THE UPCOMING
HOLIDAY SEASON.
THE INVESTMENT
FROM ROBERT
HAS ALLOWED US
TO EXPAND OUR PRODUCT LINE.
THE FIRST THING IS
OUR U.S.A. JUMPSUIT,
WHICH IS PRETTY EPIC.
Mendelson: BEFORE, WE WERE JUST
SELLING HOLIDAY SWEATERS.
NOW WE'RE SELLING
ST. PATRICK'S DAY SHIRTS,
VALENTINE'S SHIRTS,
4th OF JULY APPAREL,
AND LOTS OF
OTHER FUN PRODUCTS.
Morton:
WE REALLY BELIEVE THAT BY
DIVERSIFYING OUR PRODUCT LINE,
WE CAN MAKE TIPSY ELVES
A $50-MILLION-A-YEAR COMPANY.
Man: JUMP.
[ CAMERA SHUTTER CLICKS ]
HOW'S IT GOING, GUYS?
Morton: NOT ONLY HAVE
OUR SALES BEEN GROWING,
BUT OUR TIPSY ELVES TEAM
IS, TOO.
WE'VE HIRED TWO NEW DEVELOPERS,
AN OPERATIONS TEAM,
AND A TEAM OF
INTERNET-MARKETING CONSULTANTS.
HEY, ROBERT.
HERJAVEC: Hey, guys.
Mendelson: IT'S AMAZING
THAT SOMEONE AS BUSY AS ROBERT
HAS MADE HIMSELF SO AVAILABLE
TO TIPSY ELVES.
WE'RE GONNA BE DONATING
SOME MONEY TO TOYS FOR TOTS.
It's great to make money,
and it's better to give it back.
THANKS TO "SHARK TANK" AND
THE RAPID GROWTH OF TIPSY ELVES,
WE'RE REALLY EXCITED
TO BE MAKING A LARGE DONATION
TO TOYS FOR TOTS
THIS YEAR.
GOING ON "SHARK TANK"
WAS ONE OF THE BEST DECISIONS
OF OUR LIVES.
IT'S COMPLETELY ACCELERATED
OUR BUSINESS,
AND IF WE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY,
WE WOULD 100% DO IT AGAIN.
All: HAPPY HOLIDAYS
FROM TIPSY ELVES!
[ ALL CHEER ]
Narrator:
NEXT INTO THE TANK IS
A BETTER WAY
TO WARM UP BY THE FIREPLACE.
HEY, SHARKS.
MY NAME'S TOM SANETTI.
I'M FROM HUNTINGTON BEACH,
CALIFORNIA.
MY PRODUCT IS
EARTH-LOG FIRE PRODUCTS.
I'M HERE SEEKING AN INVESTMENT
OF $160,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 20%
OF MY FAST-GROWING BUSINESS.
EARTH-LOG FIRE LOGS ARE
A MANUFACTURED FIRE LOG,
AND WE'RE JUST LIKE
ALL THE OTHER GUYS,
BUT WE'RE COMPLETELY DIFFERENT.
EARTH-LOGS ARE MADE
USING 100% RECYCLED RESOURCES.
THEY BURN UP TO THREE TIMES
HOTTER THAN WOOD,
PRODUCE UP TO 80% LESS SMOKE,
AND THE LITTLE SMOKE YOU GET
SMELLS GREAT.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE THREE PRODUCTS
ON THE MARKET.
WE HAVE OUR ORIGINAL
EARTH-LOG FIRE LOG,
WE HAVE A CITRONELLA FIRE LOG,
AND WE HAVE
OUR INSTANT BONFIRE BLOCK.
OUR MOTTO AT EARTH-LOG
IS SIMPLE --
MORE HEAT, LESS SMOKE,
GREAT SCENT.
WE BELIEVE OUR FIRE PRODUCTS
ARE THE BEST FIRE PRODUCTS
AVAILABLE ON THE MARKET.
SO, COME ON, SHARKS.
WHO WANTS TO MAKE SOME GREEN
WHILE WE BURN GREEN?
O'Leary:
TOM, I'M YOUR CUSTOMER.
I BUY ABOUT 10 CASES OF THESE
EVERY YEAR FROM COSTCO.
I'M NOT BRAND-LOYAL.
THEY'RE ALL THE SAME.
SO HOW DO YOU COMMUNICATE
TO ME
THAT THE EARTH-LOG
IS DIFFERENT
THAN THE OTHER LOG
THAT I'M BUYING ALL THE TIME?
OURS IS THE ONLY FIRE LOG
THAT DOESN'T SMELL TERRIBLE,
BECAUSE
WE USE ONLY REFINED --
BUT HOW
DO YOU TELL ME THAT?
HOW DO YOU COMMUNICATE THAT
TO ME WHEN I'M WALKING
DOWN THE AISLE OF COSTCO
BUYING 10 CASES?
THAT'S WHY I'M HERE.
I NEED HELP WITH THE MARKETING.
AH. BECAUSE YOU HAVEN'T --
AMONGST OTHER THINGS.
HERE I AM.
BUT -- BUT
THESE ARE KEY QUESTIONS.
I'M YOUR NUMBER-ONE CUSTOMER
ON EARTH,
AND I'VE NEVER
HEARD OF YOU.
WE HAVE
VERY LIMITED DISTRIBUTION.
TOM, CAN WE SEE
YOUR PRODUCT?
PLEASE.
LET ME GRAB THESE FOR YOU.
Greiner: AND THIS IS
WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE INSIDE.
AND HERE'S
WHAT THEY LOOK LIKE INSIDE.
OKAY.
SMELLS GOOD.
WHAT DOES ONE OF THESE
COST THE CUSTOMER?
A CASE OF SIX,
THEY RUN AROUND $20 TO $22.
WHAT DOES
THE COMPETITION COST?
A CASE OF SIX.
AND WHAT IS ONE?
WE ACTUALLY GO FOR $1 LESS THAN
WHAT THEY'RE SELLING THEM FOR.
IS THERE ANOTHER
"EARTH-FRIENDLY" LOG OUT THERE?
THERE ARE,
BUT NONE OF THEM ARE SCENTED.
BUT I'M NOT COMPETING
WITH THEM.
THEY'RE ACTUALLY COMPETING
WITH ME.
I HAVE A BETTER PRODUCT,
AND THEY KNOW IT.
LET'S TALK ABOUT
THE BUSINESS.
WE'VE HAD
ABOUT 200,000 IN SALES.
O'Leary: DOLLARS?
IN WHAT PERIOD OF TIME?
SINCE WHEN?
IT'S A FOUR-YEAR PERIOD,
BUT WHAT YOU
HAVE TO UNDERSTAND IS --
$200,000 IN FOUR YEARS?
WHAT YOU
HAVE TO UNDERSTAND IS
I DIDN'T START THIS
AS A BUSINESS.
IT HAPPENED ORGANICALLY
AND ACCIDENTALLY.
WHAT HAPPENED
IN THE LAST YEAR IN SALES?
WE ONLY DID $50,000 LAST YEAR,
BUT LET ME --
I KNOW
YOU DON'T LIKE THAT ANSWER.
I HATE THE ANSWER.
WE DID $100,000
THE YEAR BEFORE.
LAST YEAR, SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
HAD ITS HOTTEST WINTER
IN 100 YEARS.
THAT MEANS YOU'RE NOT SELLING
OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA.
ABSOLUTELY. WE ARE NOT.
THE NORTHEAST HAD ITS COLDEST
WINTER SINCE YOU WERE BORN.
WE DIDN'T HAVE
THE DISTRIBUTION
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T HAVE
THE MANUFACTURING.
I WENT FROM MAKING THESE
IN MY KITCHEN
FOR MYSELF
AND MY FRIENDS --
MY FRIENDS SAID, "YOU SHOULD
TAKE IT TO THE LOCAL MARKET
AND TRY TO SELL IT."
I TOOK IT
JUST TO THE NEIGHBORHOOD MARKET.
HE SOLD OUT IN ABOUT A WEEK.
SO I SAID, "WOW. I'M GONNA GO
TO THE OTHER MARKET."
EVERYBODY WAS
SELLING THEM OUT.
SO I SAID, "I THINK
I'VE GOT SOMETHING HERE."
I STARTED MAKING
MORE AND MORE OF THEM.
WE WOULD PUT THEM
IN A BARREL,
PUT IT IN THE FORM,
AND PRESS THEM BY HAND.
THIS IS A COMMODITY BUSINESS,
OKAY?
YES.
THERE'S FOUR OR FIVE RETAILERS
THAT HAVE 80% OF THE MARKET.
I'LL NAME TWO --
COSTCO, HOME DEPOT.
OKAY.
SO, WHEN YOU CALLED THOSE BUYERS
WITH YOUR CLAIMS
THAT YOU WERE BETTER,
WHAT DID THEY SAY TO YOU?
WELL, FIRST OF ALL,
I HEARD MARK CUBAN SAY,
"NOBODY DOESN'T RETURN
MY CALL."
UNFORTUNATELY FOR ME,
NOBODY RETURNS MY CALLS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I'VE SUBMITTED
TO HOME DEPOT --
THAT'S YOUR ANSWER?
NO, I WANT TO TELL YOU --
I'VE BEEN TO
ALL MY LOCAL HOME DEPOTS,
AND THE MANAGERS SAY,
"WE LOVE IT,
"BUT YOU HAVE TO GO TO ATLANTA
TO SUBMIT,
OR YOU HAVE TO GO ONLINE."
YOU ALSO MENTIONED COSTCO.
COSTCO WANTS US
TO GO INTO THEIR STORES.
OKAY.
THEY OFFERED US
A FOUR-STORE DEAL.
I'M HOLDING OFF ON THAT
RIGHT NOW.
WHY?
HOW CAN YOU SELL SOMETHING
THAT YOU DON'T HAVE?
WHAT, AM I GONNA GO TO COSTCO
AND TELL THEM
"SURE, HERE'S OUR GREAT PRODUCT"
AND THEN THEY WANT TO ORDER IT,
AND I SAY, "SORRY.
I CAN'T FILL YOUR ORDER"?
IF YOU'RE GONNA TRY
AND ATTRACT AN INVESTOR HERE,
THERE HAS TO BE
A DISTRIBUTION STRATEGY, OKAY?
WHY DON'T YOU PICK
ONE NATIONAL RETAILER?
I HAVE
A LETTER OF INTENT.
ALL RIGHT, FROM WHO?
WE JUST CLOSED A DEAL
FROM ONE OF THE LARGEST GROCERS
IN THE COUNTRY, ALBERTSONS.
GROCERS? OKAY.
WOW.
TEST OR NATIONAL ROLLOUT?
WELL, THEY WANTED US
TO GO NATIONAL,
AND I TOLD THEM, BECAUSE OF
OUR LIMITED DISTRIBUTION STILL,
WE WANT TO DO
THE 180 CALIFORNIA STORES
UNTIL WE CAN
INCREASE PRODUCTION.
WOULD THEY HAVE TAKEN YOU
TO MORE THAN 180
IF YOU COULD HAVE
SUPPLIED THEM?
YES, THEY ACTUALLY WANTED US
TO GO INTO 3,200 STORES.
Greiner: REALLY?
HEY! GOOD FOR YOU.
LAST YEAR, ANOTHER
NATIONAL RETAIL GROCERY STORE,
VONS PAVILIONS,
ASKED US TO GO IN, AS WELL.
THEY SAID THEIR MINIMUM ORDER
WOULD BE 22 TRAILERS.
I SAID, "THERE'S NO WAY
I COULD DO THAT IN 22 YEARS."
WHAT'S YOUR SOLUTION
FOR THAT?
AUTOMATION.
AND THAT'S WHY I'M HERE.
I'M LOOKING FOR THE FUNDING
TO BUILD THE MACHINES
TO GET US
TO FULL AUTOMATION.
DO THOSE MACHINES
CURRENTLY EXIST?
THEY DON'T.
WE ACTUALLY HAVE A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT PROPRIETARY PROCESS
THAT WE'VE JUST RECENTLY
FILED FOR PATENTS FOR.
WHAT IS THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THIS AND DURAFLAME...
WELL, FIRST, LET ME --
LET ME ADDRESS --
...OTHER THAN THE SCENTS?
ALL THE OTHER FIRE LOGS ARE MADE
FROM SAWDUST AND SLACK WAX.
SLACK WAX IS A VERY HEAVILY
OIL-LADEN, SMELLY WAX.
I LOVE IT.
I WILL BE A CUSTOMER
BECAUSE IT'S A GREAT PRODUCT,
BUT IT'S NOT YET
A COMPANY.
I'VE GOT TO BE ABLE
TO SAY,
"IS IT WORTH MY TIME
AND MY TEAM'S TIME
TO TAKE THIS FROM GROUND ZERO
TO WHERE YOU THINK IT COULD GO?"
IF YOU WERE FURTHER ALONG,
YEAH, RIGHT?
BUT YOU'RE NOT TO THE POINT
WHERE YOU JUST NEED PHONE CALLS.
YOU NEED EVERYTHING,
AND EVERYTHING IS A LOT OF WORK,
AND THAT'S WHY I'M OUT.
OKAY.
I AGREE WITH MARK.
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK
TO BUILD THE ORGANIZATION
AROUND YOU.
THIS IS OUT OF
THE GoPro PLAYBOOK --
WE ALWAYS KNEW WE HAD
A REALLY BIG OPPORTUNITY,
BUT WE RECOGNIZED
WE WERE, LIKE, EIGHT PEOPLE,
AND WE NEEDED TO START
WITH SMALL RETAILERS,
BUILD A BRAND,
BUILD AN ORGANIZATION, YOU KNOW,
AND WHEN BEST BUY CALLED,
WE WERE READY FOR IT.
AND I THINK
YOU'RE TRYING TO GO
FROM ZERO TO 1,000 MILES AN HOUR
RIGHT AWAY.
I THINK YOU'LL SUCCEED,
BUT BECAUSE YOU HAVE
SO MUCH WORK TO DO,
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
TOM, LISTEN, UM,
I THINK YOU HAVE
A REALLY AMAZING PRODUCT,
BUT I THINK YOU HAVE
A LOT OF STEPS TO GO.
I THINK YOU WILL MAKE IT,
BUT YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO
FIGURE IT OUT.
IT'S A LITTLE TOO EARLY
FOR ME.
SO WITH THAT, I'M OUT.
OKAY.
YOU KNOW,
WHEN I WAS IN THE BASEMENT
BACK IN THE LATE '80s
STARING THE LEARNING COMPANY,
AND AFTER I'D GO GET
A $12 MILLION ORDER
FOR READER RABBIT,
IT WOULD BLOW UP BEHIND ME --
THE LOGISTICS.
I COULDN'T DELIVER.
AND I MET A GUY
NAMED MIKE PERIK.
I GAVE HIM HALF MY EQUITY
TO SOLVE MY PROBLEM.
WE SOLD THE COMPANY
FOR $4.2 BILLION 5 YEARS LATER.
BEST INVESTMENT
I EVER MADE.
YOU HAVE TO FIND
YOUR MIKE PERIK.
THAT'S WHY I'M HERE.
I DON'T WANT A JOB.
I JUST WANT
TO INVEST MY MONEY
SO I CAN SIT ON THE DOCK
WITH MY TOES IN THE WATER.
LOOK, I HAVE
A CERTAIN SENSE OF FRUSTRATION,
BUT I SEE ME IN YOU.
GO FIND YOUR MICHAEL PERIK.
DO IT.
YOU'LL MAKE
A LOT OF MONEY.
GOOD LUCK. I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
IT'S YOU AND I.
AND THEN THERE WAS ONE.
YES.
YOU KNOW, YOU MAKE ME THINK OF
A PRODUCT CALLED ScreenMend,
WHICH PATCHED YOUR SCREENS.
LOVE IT.
THEY WERE MAKING IT
OUT OF THE GARAGE.
I LOVED THE PRODUCT.
I THOUGHT IT WAS BRILLIANT.
SO I TOOK A GAMBLE
ON THEM.
TO DATE, WE'VE DONE
$1 MILLION IN SALES IN A YEAR.
I LOVE YOUR PRODUCT.
I LIKE THE NAME --
EARTH-LOG.
I THINK
IT'S SUPER-APPEALING.
I LOVE
THAT THEY SMELL GOOD.
EVERYTHING ABOUT THIS,
I LIKE.
SO I'M GONNA MAKE YOU
AN OFFER.
AND IT'S GONNA BE
A BLOODSUCKING ONE.
[ CHUCKLES ]
I'M GONNA MAKE YOU AN OFFER,
STILL AN OFFER.
BUT IT'S GONNA BE
A REALISTIC OFFER
BECAUSE I KNOW
WHAT IT'S GOING TO TAKE
TO TAKE YOU
FROM WHERE YOU ARE
TO ACTUALLY BEING ABLE
TO MANUFACTURE THIS,
GET THIS OUT
INTO RETAILERS EVERYWHERE.
SO I'M GONNA OFFER YOU
$160,000,
BUT I'D LIKE 35%.
AND RIGHT NOW, YOU KNOW,
ALL THE PLACES ScreenMend IS --
BED BATH & BEYOND,
HOME DEPOT, LOWE'S --
I THINK THAT I CAN GET YOU
INTO ALL OF THESE PLACES, TOO.
DEAL.
DEAL!
[ LAUGHS ]
YAY!
THAT WAS EASY.
[ LAUGHS ]
LORI, THAT WAS NOT
A BLOODSUCKING OFFER.
AWESOME! YAY!
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
I THINK WE'RE GONNA
BLOW THIS THING UP.
I LOVE IT.
HEY, TOM, HOW ABOUT
A LITTLE NEGOTIATION?
I DIDN'T NEED IT.
I THINK IT WAS A FAIR DEAL.
CONGRATULATIONS, TOM.
YOU WERE GREAT,
AND I'M VERY, VERY HAPPY
THAT LORI DID THAT.
YEAH, IT'S GREAT.
GOOD. NOW I'LL GO OUT
AND BUY SOME FOR YOU.
THANKS, YOU GUYS.
I APPRECIATE IT.
CONGRATS, TOM.
I'M FEELING ALL WARM AND FUZZY.
I LOVE IT.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANKS, YOU GUYS.
Sanetti:
CHICKS DIG EARTH-LOG,
SO I KNEW LORI WOULD BE
THE PERFECT PARTNER.
DREAMS COME TRUE IN AMERICA
THANKS TO THE SHARK TANK.